y esta cuestión es que aquí está
longitud de onda solo se refiere a una
longitud de onda pero vamos a tener
cierta longitud de onda en el aire o en
este material uno voy a llamarle lambda
a que puede ser la del aire o de
cualquier material que se encuentre aquí
y voy a tener otra longitud de onda en
el aceite que le voy a llamar lambda b y
esta longitud de onda va a ser diferente
de la que teníamos aquí arriba lambda ah
y esto se debe a la diferencia de la
velocidad incluso podría tener una
longitud de onda diferente aquí en el
agua aunque aquí no me preocupo por esta
porque no me interesa la luz que pasa
aquí a través del agua así que mejor
esto no lo tomamos en cuenta para evitar
confusiones pues aunque algo de la luz
pase por acá esta no va a llegar a mi
ojo así que no me interesa en este
ejemplo cuál longitud de onda debo de
usar aquí la que se encuentra en el aire
lambda a la que se encuentra en el
aceite lambda
pues siempre vamos a ocupar la lambda
del aceite que corresponde a la longitud
de onda en la película delgada así que
tanto esta landa como esta lambda
corresponden a la longitud de onda en la
película delgada
y q la delgada
y esto se debe a que esta es la longitud
de onda donde se viajó la distancia
extra esta es mi delta x y se encuentra
toda en la película delgada y esto es
porque me interesa que tan adelante está
saliendo la otra onda si por ejemplo
este rayo comenzaba en este punto y
ahora quiero ver este otro rayo o esta
otra onda que tan adelante va a salir
por ejemplo si tenemos esta longitud de
onda y nuestro primer rayo salió en esta
fase pero este otro sale en esta
quiere decir que están en fase tendremos
interferencia constructiva pero si este
rayo sale en este punto entonces
tendremos interferencia destructiva ya
que aquí tendremos un desplazamiento de
180 grados por lo que queremos saber qué
tanto ha progresado este ciclo cuando
regresa este rayo a nuestro ojo y es por
eso que usamos esta longitud de onda la
de este medio es la que nos interesa sin
embargo en muchas ocasiones no nos dan
la longitud de onda en la película
delgada sino la longitud de onda en el
aire o cualquiera que sea el material
que tenemos aquí bueno si nos dan como
dato la longitud de onda en este
material como es que podemos encontrar
la longitud de onda en la película
delgada bueno no es tan difícil
bueno la forma más sencilla y directa de
pensar en esto es analizar la frecuencia
la frecuencia no va a cambiar sin
importar en qué material esté
la frecuencia de nuestra onda en el
medio
va a ser igual a la frecuencia de esta
onda en el medio ve la frecuencia está
determinada por la fuente si este rayo
de luz vino del sol o de un láser esto
es lo que va a determinar la frecuencia
de esta onda o de este rayo de luz y
esto se va a mantener no importa que
pase ya sea que se retracte que se
refleje etcétera la frecuencia siempre
se mantiene igual y este es un dato muy
útil al menos en este caso porque nos
permite encontrar la longitud de onda
como relacionamos la frecuencia con la
longitud de onda pues mediante la
velocidad la velocidad va a ser igual a
la longitud de onda por la frecuencia si
quiero encontrar la frecuencia dividido
a ambos lados entre la longitud y me
queda que la frecuencia es igual a la
velocidad entre la longitud de onda esto
lo voy a sustituir acá aquí tengo que
esta frecuencia en el medio a es igual a
la velocidad en a
entre la longitud de onda todo esto
viene de esta fórmula y esta es la
longitud de onda en el medio
y nuestra frecuencia en el medio ve que
en este caso es el aceite va a ser igual
a la velocidad de la luz en el medio de
entre la longitud de esta misma luz en
este medio ahora voy a despejar la
longitud de onda en el medio b y me va a
quedar que la longitud de onda en mi
película delgada es igual multiplico
ambos lados por la longitud de onda en
vez
hacemos algunas multiplicaciones y nos
queda que la longitud de onda en la
película delgada va a ser igual a la
velocidad
en el medio ve entre la velocidad en el
medio
y todo esto está multiplicado por la
longitud de onda en el medio y esta es
una manera de determinar la longitud de
la onda en la película delgada si nos
dan como dato la velocidad como es en
este caso aquí tenemos la velocidad de
la luz en el aire que incluso ustedes la
pueden encontrar y aquí también les di
la velocidad de la luz en el aceite así
que con estos datos tomamos la
proporción de la velocidad en la
película delgada entre la velocidad en
el medio exterior multiplicada por la
longitud de onda en este medio sacamos
la proporción dividiendo la velocidad en
el segundo medio entre la velocidad del
primer medio y todo esto lo
multiplicamos por la longitud de onda en
el primer medio como tenemos aquí y así
obtenemos la longitud de onda en el
segundo medio y este es el dato que
vamos a usar en estas fórmulas de aquí y
qué pasa si no nos dan como dato estas
velocidades que está si nos dan
solamente el índice de refracción y
digamos
chispas como lo vamos a hacer así que
bueno nos dan el índice de refracción en
la región
y también el índice de refracción en la
región ve que vamos a hacer bueno
recuerden que el índice de refracción
está definido como la velocidad de la
luz en el vacío entre la velocidad de la
luz en este medio así que en ella o el
índice de refracción del medio
va a ser igual a 3 por 10 a la 8 entre
la velocidad en este medio y el índice
de refracción en el medio b va a ser
igual a 3 por 10 a la 8 entre la
velocidad en este medio ve cómo podemos
usar esto aquí bueno vamos a despejar
nuestra velocidad
en este caso voy a tener que mi
velocidad en 'la es igual a la velocidad
de la luz en el vacío entre el índice de
refracción en a y la velocidad en el
medio d es igual a la velocidad de la
luz en el vacío entre el índice de
refracción en vez y ahora voy a
sustituir ambos valores aquí así que
tomo aunque me estoy quedando sin
espacio todo esto de la velocidad de mbe
y lo pongo aquí
y todo esto de la velocidad de na
y lo pongo aquí y ahora voy a tener una
nueva condición
esto me queda como lambda b
es igual a la velocidad en que lo
sustituimos por esto y es que entre el
índice de refracción debe entre esta
velocidad de na que es la velocidad de
la luz entre el índice de refracción en
qué nos queda aquí y esto lo multiplicó
por lambda
puedo simplificar esto puedo cancelar
estas sedes aquí y me quedaría uno entre
n b entre 1 entre n a que es lo mismo
que tener n
/ m y todo esto multiplicado por lambda
y esta es otra condición que podemos
usar esta es otra forma de encontrar la
longitud de onda en la película delgada
pero ahora con los índices de refracción
si nos dan las velocidades tomamos esta
proporción la velocidad en la película
delgada entre la velocidad en el primer
medio pero si nos dan los índices de
refracción va a ser el índice de
refracción en el medio externo dividido
entre el índice de refracción de la
película delgada y todo esto
multiplicado por lambda
y ustedes pueden decirme esto es mucha
información como me voy a acordar de
todo esto la forma en la que yo recuerdo
esto es que yo sé que si paso del aire
hacia el aceite la velocidad va a
disminuir y si la velocidad disminuye
sabemos que la frecuencia no cambia
entonces si la velocidad disminuye la
longitud de onda también va a disminuir
esto es para cuando me dan las
velocidades
y yo veo que aquí me están dando mis
proporciones si me están dando las n
tengo que asegurarme que la proporción
de esta división de manera que esta
longitud sea menor que ésta tiene que
ser menor a 1 para que mi longitud en la
película delgada sea menor que la
longitud en el medio 1 y si me dan las
velocidades tengo que elegir las de
manera que su proporción me dé una
lambda más pequeña que esta división
acomodar la de manera que me dé menor a
1 para que al multiplicada por esta el
resultado sea una longitud menor aunque
aquí tienen que asegurarse de que están
pasando de un medio más rápido a uno más
lento puede que les pongan problemas en
donde pasan de un medio más lento a uno
más rápido si tienen el caso de que el
medio 1 es más lento que el de la
película delgada tienen que asegurarse
que la proporción aquí esté de tal
manera que les dé una longitud de onda
si de plano no se acuerdan siempre
pueden recurrir a esta relación de que
las frecuencias sin importar en qué
medio estén van a ser las mismas estos
son los tres elementos que tenemos que
cuidar cuando trabajamos con la
interferencia de película delgada estas
son nuestras condiciones y hay que
asegurarse si tenemos un desfase de pi
también tenemos que asegurarnos de usar
la longitud de onda de la película
delgada y todo esto que se ve bastante
desordenado y les pido una disculpa por
eso todo esto podemos ponerlo en una
super fórmula que concentre toda esta
información limpiamos este desastre que
es lo que sabemos bueno sabemos que para
tener una interferencia constructiva
debemos tener aquí dos
que es igual a un entero m que puede ser
0 1 2 3 x la longitud de onda en la
película delgada pero no quiero estar
despejando ese valor cada vez eso ya lo
hicimos así que vamos a multiplicar esto
por esta región la voy a llamar a a esta
región le voy a llamar b y entonces
tendré que voy a multiplicar por la
velocidad en la película delgada entre
la velocidad en el medio
a todo esto multiplicado por la longitud
de onda en el medio a que muchas veces
es el aire y con esto tendremos la
interferencia constructiva o si tenemos
suerte y nos dan el índice de refracción
esto va a ser nuestro entero m x el
índice de refracción en el medio a entre
el índice de refracción en el medio de
todo esto multiplicado por la longitud
de onda en él
y esto es lo que necesitamos para
encontrar la interferencia constructiva
constructiva y lo mismo podemos hacer
para encontrar la interferencia
destructiva esto es igual a como son
mitades de onda va a ser m más un medio
multiplicado por lo mismo si nos dan las
velocidades la velocidad en el medio de
la película delgada entre la velocidad
en el medio a por lambda
y de nuevo si nos dan los índices de
refracción vamos a tener las mitades
aquí por el índice de refracción en el
medio a entre el índice de refracción en
el medio be de la película delgada x
lambda
y esto nos va a dar las interferencias
destructivas
y la única cosa que tenemos que cuidar
es si hay un desfasamiento de pie en
estas ondas
si esto ocurre vamos a intercambiar
estas condiciones
ahora las mitades de la longitud de onda
nos darán la interferencia constructiva
y los múltiplos enteros de la longitud
de onda nos dará la interferencia
destructiva esto ocurre si solo una de
las ondas
tiene desplazamiento
tiene desfasamiento
pink o de 180 grados
si esto ocurre entonces vamos a
intercambiar estas condiciones aunque
todavía esto luce un poco intimidante a
veces esto puede simplificarse un poco
si esta región uno es el aire si esto es
aire entonces el índice de refracción en
el aire es igual a 1 si ese es el caso
se puede simplificar esto un poco ya que
esto valdrá 1 y esto de aquí también
valdrá 1 de manera que para la
interferencia constructiva tendremos m
por lambda
entre el índice de refracción en la
película delgada
si queremos la interferencia destructiva
tendremos las mitades de lambda a entre
el inicio de reflexión debe y esto la
tendremos para todas aquellas ms que
sean igual a 0 o 123 etcétera
podemos tener m igual a 0 digamos que si
siempre es igual a cero quiere decir que
el grosor de la película delgada es
prácticamente cero si este grosor es
cero quiere decir que no tenemos una
película delgada o algo así
y el grosor de esta película delgada es
mucho más pequeño comparado con la
longitud de la onda este grosor t este
grosor t es más pequeño comparada con la
longitud de onda de la luz pues es como
si este grosor no existiera y esto nos
va a dar una interferencia constructiva
o destructiva dependiendo si hay
desfasamiento o no en la onda y esto
tiene varias aplicaciones la cubierta
anti reflejante justamente hace eso
tiene una película tan delgada en
comparación con la longitud de onda de
la luz que hace que toda la luz se
refleje destructivamente pues en este
caso tendremos un desplazamiento de pi y
estos enteros nos darán puntos
destructivos y de esto se trata la
interferencia de película delgada que a
veces confunde a las personas pero que
yo espero que ustedes ya sepan cómo
trabajar